♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHEN YOU ARE FACED
WITH THE EMULATION THAT EXPOSES
HOW BADLY MOST OF THE NEWS,
YOU'VE GOT TWO OPTIONS.
ADMIT YOUR MISTAKES AND LEARN
FROM THEM OR B, CIRCLE THE
WAGONS AND DIG A DEEPER GRAVE.
GUESS WHAT THE MEDIA CHOSE?
>> WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE HAD THE
MEDIA DO OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS?
SHOULD WE HAVE REPORTED ON HORSE
FARMS IN KENTUCKY?
OR DONE INVESTIGATIONS ABOUT
EATING TREE BARK?
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE US DO?
>> Greg: I WOULD'VE READ THAT
STORY ABOUT TREE BARK.
LET'S COMPARE.
RACHEL MADDOW FROM LAST WEEK.
>> MY FAVORITE NAME IN THE WHOLE
TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
IF THERE WASN'T A PERSON
INVOLVED WITH HIS NAME, YOU HAVE
TO INVENT ONE.
>> Greg: HERE IS HER NOW.
>> IN 1974, LEON JAWORSKI WAS
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING WATERGATE.
FOR A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAD
BEEN ARCHIBALD COX.
>> Greg: WITHOUT RUSSIA, SHE
IS REDUCED TO DOING A HISTORY
CLASS FOR SHOUTING.
SHE HAS ONE MONTH FROM
SCRIBBLING HELP ME ON A
CHALKBOARD.
NEXT WEEK SHE'LL BE SAYING THIS.
>> WE ARE REALLY FREAKING OLD.
AND CABLE NEWS YEARS, WE ARE
LIKE 1,000.
LIKE GREAT UNCLE PETE, ALWAYS
FALLING ASLEEP IN THE MASHED
POTATOES.
WE ARE IN THE EEL STILL SWIMMING
AROUND NEW ZEALAND READY TO
EMBARK ON ITS NEXT PHASE OF
MYSTERIOUS FISH LIFE.
>> Greg: CNN HONCHO JEFF
ZUCKER EXCUSES HIS GUILT, SAYING
WE ARE NOT INVESTIGATORS.
WE ARE JOURNALISTS.
HE ADMITS HIS ANCHORS ARE ONLY
STENOGRAPHERS, NOT PEOPLE
CAPABLE OF FERRETING OUT FACTS.
THAT DOESN'T EXPLAIN WHY THEY
CLIMBED INTO BED WITH MICHAEL
AVENATTI AS HE TRIED TO DESTROY
AN INNOCENT MAN.
NOW HE'S BEEN ARRESTED AND ONE
OF CNN'S FORMER LEGAL ANALYSTS
MAY HAVE BEEN INVOLVED.
I CALL IT A BAD WEEK FOR CNN BUT
IT'S JUST ANOTHER WEEK FOR CNN.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE SOME
INTROSPECTION FROM MEDIA, MAYBE
ASK THEMSELVES HOW DID WE FALL
FOR THIS ONE DID WE PLAY A ROLE
IN FOOLING OTHERS?
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THERE IS
PROFIT IN THIS NARRATIVE, A
NARRATIVE SO DIVISIVE THAT COULD
HAVE DESTROYED THE COUNTRY.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEY STILL DON'T.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY GOT CAUGHT.
WHAT DO THESE PEOPLE DO WHEN
THEY'VE DRIVEN THEIR PROFESSION
INTO THE GROUND?
THERE IS ALWAYS VAUDEVILLE.
>> [SINGING]
♪ ♪
>> ♪♪ WE COULD USE A MAN LIKE
HERBERT HOOVER AGAIN ♪♪
>> Greg: THERE'S ALWAYS A
BACKUP PLAN.
THE MEDIA SEEMS TO BE IN A
DEFENSIVE MODE.
>> Dana: THEY ARE BUT THEY'VE
GOT A PLAN.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT IS?
THEY'RE GOING TO GO AFTER, ONE,
THEY WILL SAY BILL BARR IS
COMPROMISED BECAUSE MUELLER DID
NOT MAKE A DECISION ON
OBSTRUCTION, THOUGH AS ANDY
McCARTHY POINTS OUT, THAT WAS
HIS JOB.
WHAT DID WE PAY YOU FOR?
YOUR JOB AS A PROSECUTOR'S TO
MAKE A DECISION.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN DO THAT, SO NOW
JERRY NADLER AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO SAY
BARR, CAN WE SEE YOU?
MUELLER, COULD WE SEE YOU?
COULD YOU EXPLAIN HOW YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN APOLITICAL
REPORT AND NOW IT'S TOTALLY
COMPROMISED BECAUSE YOU LET A
POLITICAL APPOINTEE DECIDE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT GUILTY OF
OBSTRUCTION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE THEY ARE
HEADING.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WATCH THE
OTHER CHANNELS.
>> Greg: IS IT REALLY THE
MEDIA OF THE DEEP STATE?
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU'RE ONTO
SOMETHING.
THE MORNING JOE CLIP YOU PLAYED,
IT'S A STRAWMAN ARGUMENT.
WE ARE NOT SAYING WE WANT YOU TO
REPORT ON HORSE FARMS IN
KENTUCKY.
JUST REPORT THE STORY FAIRLY AND
REPORTED FROM BOTH SIDES.
YOU CAN STILL REPORT ON THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION INVESTIGATION
BUT LOOK AROUND YOU.
DON'T JUST LOOK ON ONE SIDE OF
THE STORY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
FOX DID AND THEN WE BENEFITED
FROM THAT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN NOW
AND YOU SAW THE RATINGS LAST
NIGHT.
THE RATINGS FOR FOX WERE
ASTRONOMICAL ON THE RATINGS FOR
CNN WERE LOWER THAN USUAL AND
MSNBC REALLY SOFT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A HANGOVER.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FEEL
DECEIVED.
IF I WERE REVIEWER, I WOULD FEEL
MISLED.
YOU KNOW YOU FEEL LIKE YOU PUT
ALL YOUR EGGS IN ONE BASKET AND
THEN IT DOESN'T DELIVER, YOU GOT
TO TAKE A BREAK FROM TV.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WATCH TV FOR
LITTLE WHILE.
I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
STOPPED WATCHING TV AFTER ROMNEY
LOST BECAUSE THE MEDIA TOLD THEM
ROMNEY WAS GOING TO WIN AND HUGE
LANDSLIDE AND WHEN THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN, THEY TUNED OUT FOR,
MONTHS AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL
SEE FROM THE REST OF THE PRESS.
>> Greg: JUAN, WHY IS IT SO
HARD TO SAY WE GOT IT WRONG?
>> Juan: I AM STILL WAITING
BECAUSE WHAT I, I THOUGHT WHAT
JEFF ZUCKER SAID WAS ON TARGET.
>> Dana: REPORTERS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE
ON AIR, LIKE JOHN BRENNAN.
>> Juan: THE QUESTION WAS
ABOUT THE MEDIA IN GENERAL ABOUT
THE PULITZER PRIZES THAT WENT TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ."
THEY SAY WIRE WITH HIS AWARDS
GIVEN TO THESE JOURNALISTS WHEN
HERE'S THE FINDING OF THE
MUELLER SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IN FACT, THE MEDIA DOESN'T HAVE
THE POWER TO PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL
TO INVESTIGATE A FOREIGN POWER
TRYING TO SUBVERT AN AMERICAN
ELECTION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S DONE BY
PEOPLE IN POWER AND THE
JOURNALIST'S JOB IS REPORT ON I
IT.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE TO VET
TOO.
>> Juan: JESSE, YOU SAID NO
ATTENTION TO THE CONTRARY SET OF
FACTS COMING FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
TO THE CONTRARY, WE PUT TRUMP ON
TV EVERY DAY SAYING NO
COLLUSION, WITCH HUNT,
DEEP STATE.
>> Jesse: DID MSNBC
INVESTIGATE THE DOSSIER, THE
PETER STRZOK TEXTS?
NOT AS MUCH AS WE DID.
>> Morgan: THERE ARE SOME
RESPONSIBLE JOURNALISTS.
ABC, TERRY MORAN, HE SAID THESE
PEOPLE WHO CAME FORWARD AND SAID
THESE THINGS LIKE BRENNAN AND
THE LIST OF DEMOCRATIC
OPERATIVES MASKING THEMSELVES AS
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS HAVING
ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
TREASON.
HE SAID I'M GOING TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THOSE PEOPLE AND DEMAND
MORE EVIDENCE.
I HOPE MORE PEOPLE FOLLOW THIS
HONEST REPORTER AND DON'T JUST
TAKE WHATEVER THE DEMOCRATS --